[Music]
chess.com is here with world
championship challenger jan napomischi
who has graciously decided to have an
interview with us a few days after uh
the world championship has ended so
thank you young
uh now yesterday was the first day of
the last seven months where you didn't
have to prepare for the world
championship all of that weight was off
your shoulders how did you spend it
uh well uh
way better i believe than uh previous
half a year yeah but
i mean uh
it's uh
it was quite a new feeling but uh yeah
just
what can i say i slept uh
relatively well and uh just uh
you know finally i had uh nauseous uh
not just work uh you know
during uh during the daytime or night
time so i mean
in general it uh
you know feels uh feels a little bit
better but still you know the taste of
ash
in your mouth is um
probably it will uh
it will stay for uh quite some time
understandable well again you've you've
got nearly to the highest mountain in
chess as you know um now did you have
any temptation to open up your laptop
and get into any of the games especially
game six yesterday or are you really
going to leave that for a couple of
weeks before you revisit these games
no i just analyzed you know the western
game a bit but i mean especially the
opening parts because like it was i
guess quite an interesting idea quite a
musical forger which
uh was uh i mean somewhat uh
somewhat new from uh from blackside but
uh i mean okay i guess this was like
early in the morning and then okay i
just closed the laptop and uh
i guess you know they're just uh
trying to understand uh what what it was
like in
in uh
in chess terms uh what happened in
chance terms it's like it's
surely i i need some some break before i
will
uh start with work yeah we've already
asked about that at the post game press
conference the actual chess uh getting
back to your team you obviously had
sergey karjakin on your team uh please
correct me if i'm wrong if you had peter
lecko on your team
but both of those players have played
for world championships and i'm sure
they tried to describe to you what it
was going to be like to be in the tank
not chess moves but just that experience
was there uh preparation for what it was
like to play in the tank was it what you
expected or was it somehow different
well i would say that sergey just
joined us you know the last minute so
basically for the last i think month and
it was mainly about like some trainings
uh which probably as it seems right now
uh we're too intense and uh maybe not
too well timed because okay normally you
have to
[Music]
i don't know have probably some break
so i mean okay you can uh
perhaps you can also play some blitz uh
or bullets online but in general if you
try to play some uh some serious uh or
semi-serious games uh not like blizz but
i mean just uh in training purposes it's
um maybe yeah there is also a limit yeah
you shouldn't be
too you know to swallow it into into
holly into this whole topic
uh so yes uh i mean indeed uh it was
quite instructive to speak with peter
and speak with sergey about the world
championship match experience but
what i understood i mean
only after the match has started that
every match is unique
and i mean
you can even imagine yourself in
someone's shoes but uh but you know at
the same time
i mean the opponent can be different and
even it's the same person i mean this uh
this person can play completely
different chess
and uh have you know a completely
different strategy so i mean in general
okay some general advice is like i don't
know not to
don't uh even pay too much attention to
what people say like okay don't
get too
busy with some social media and so on
and so on but i mean okay these are
general these are just general words so
i mean of course i'll you know i asked a
few few questions uh
i asked you know vladimir kramnik okay
what uh what is his uh what are his
faults but yeah sadly we
couldn't work this time but uh you know
uh maybe
sometimes in the future but i mean of
course uh a lot of guys they gave me a
lot of advices and some of them
had a world championship magic
experience some of them not
and uh yeah perhaps uh nowadays i would
today i would say that maybe
uh it was like a little bit too much you
know try to
do everything correctly according to you
know all this information you get
because anyway
once again every every tournament is
more or less unique and every matches
especially especially every match is
unique
and
you got to prepare to whole new
situation like um it's a little bit uh
you know unfortunate a decision to
you know to try to
build your you know preparation on to
the experience of another people and
something crowded did not have to deal
with was social media sergey was playing
for the world championship in the social
media age were you opening up your phone
at all just to read what people said i
mean it's pretty hard to not touch your
phone for three weeks uh well i opened
but uh basically for some sports you
know i know for some sport results like
okay some food for some football
championships and so on
and uh i mean uh obviously okay if you
enter some sports portal you see some uh
some news but i was trying not to you
know look into this you know comment
section and so on so you know what was
going on but uh i guess uh okay at least
now when i
um finally yeah installed uh my social
networks back onto my iphone i think
yeah i got like quite a lot of for
support and um i'm pretty i'm pretty
thankful for
uh to tell these people because i mean
uh
yeah this really motivates you to to
work further even
after
you produced something not that
brilliant and i asked you in the middle
of the match was any part of playing the
world championship fun and i think you
basically said it it's dependent on the
result now that we're done can you look
back on any part of the actual playing
of the match and describe it as fun or
is that too uh too loose of a word for
such an experience
no obviously obviously i really
like playing chess and uh some of the
games i mean game two ability especially
was really tense and also i believe
despite the result game six was very
interesting so i mean uh was not too
much fun especially in the last couple
of hours but uh anyway you know when you
play such a complex game it's uh against
a very strong opponent it's
it's always you know in some words uh in
summoning it's always fun
and uh you know you really enjoy the
process yeah you know you really enjoy
the uh as it goes
uh so it's uh it's a big fight
but uh yep somehow most of the games uh
i'm not even speaking about okay the
second part of the match it's uh it's
not about the result i mean it was like
quite boring and uh yeah it was like
some shirt opening uh discussion and
then okay probably one of the sites
go you know get some pretty tiny
advantage
but yeah this just leads nowhere but but
to draw yeah so this is uh you know not
so not so you know exciting but
you know some some really interesting
games some wild crazy positions for us
uh somewhat i really enjoyed yeah and
what about a totally different kind of
fun we should let the viewer know
sometimes during our interview you're
going to hear the propellers of a plane
because we're right by skydive dubai and
what they can't see is a beautiful view
of jumeirah beach
would you ever do anything crazy in the
next couple of days like go skydiving no
i'm i really don't know so
so far i still need to attend the
closing ceremony yes so
after this i surely will um i will will
consider these options but yeah i as for
me i actually have never tried any you
know any extreme sports
and you know any of these uh kind of
adventures so well why not getting back
to chess it's been about 15 years since
russia has held the world championship
did you feel any added pressure to win
for your country
i wouldn't say it was an added pressure
but
yeah for me i was just trying to
do my best and
i mean as it seems to me now i really
tried too hard so this
was you know also necessary to
measure you know
uh
you know your energy level at some point
because uh
i know i know
and i thought
perhaps for the last uh you know
roughly four months i really didn't have
a you know a day off
and
i mean once you get used to this uh
you know
style of living yes or heart preparation
yeah like uh some it's a very strict
schedule and so on uh once you get used
i mean it seems that that's it's pretty
much all right yeah so you like uh you
live like this forever but in general i
mean when it comes you know to
to the showtime
uh
i guess uh sometimes you just lack your
energy because it's not like lifting
this uh i mean compare comparing with
magnus i guess he
more or less uh has this type of uh
schedule like for past like 10 years
roughly maybe more
yeah but for me was
quite a new experience so i guess
it was slightly over optimistic to
i mean
[Music]
train that hard i mean of course of
course it was extremely useful uh i mean
you know chest-wise sport wise i mean
health dies and so on uh but yeah maybe
you know
there is uh some kind of the burnout
which uh
cannot be
i mean okay i couldn't foresee it but
okay now i see it's uh it's it's quite
it's quite a thing you should be
you know really care you're really
careful about
and um i mean uh uh returning to your
question uh i mean of course yeah okay
like some huge expectations and i mean
you know first of all from uh
you know they come from inside not from
uh you know from some people who like
uh
say like uh let's return crown to russia
and so on but in general yeah it's
absolutely
not as uh important to me as
you know if you speak from my inner
expectations
and i would say uh this
uh i mean it was really high so also
this probably doesn't help you
uh too much but i mean it of course it's
helped you to focus to on your
preparation yeah i like to
uh
so basically your life changes uh
quite a lot and
i mean you start to
do everything differently but yeah
in the end
sometimes it's you know
very useful to slow down a bit
the biggest topic of discussion in the
last 24 hours has been the revealing
that daniel dubov was on magnus
carlson's team and of course we know
that he is russian is it do you feel
it's okay for one of your countrymen to
help your opponent
well uh somehow i wasn't sure about this
until game two
uh but when i saw this okay 95 idea it's
typical idea from daniel uh so i mean
i had quite a mixed feelings because i
mean it's not about like being
countrymen because i mean okay obviously
we have
uh quite a lot of stronger investors and
some of them work with each other but uh
speaking of daniel i guess we worked
together like few years ago for quite
some time so
i mean
i thought he would rather you know
uh you know be in the commentators team
but
oh you know on the other hand uh
i guess
out of our team we should
uh probably
thank him because you know these biggest
chances they arrived after his
brilliant novel gcl like this 95
in catalan and also you know the second
game like the semi-catalan semi-regime
actually game six okay yeah was also
quite uh
uh
double agent is that what you're saying
no i i don't know i don't know i don't
think he's a double engine but yeah
obviously obviously the you know the
the results of his work
were quite favorable for us would you
feel comfortable being on a national
team with him at a future olympiad
i don't think about this but i think uh
it's just it just works so i
uh being given a chance i'd like to
congratulate him with uh some some nice
results of his work uh what about your
team of seconds uh are you ever going to
reveal the full list or do we already
know the full list
i think uh
the full list won't be revealed but
comparing with the
candidates i would say that um
evgeny kobashevsky joined us
for this uh for this event okay but
uh okay petrol petroleko
of course
of course was there uh in dark heirloom
vladimir podkin who also presented uh
who was also presented here
and yeah also some other names but uh
yeah so so so far i'm not going to
reveal uh everybody uh but uh i would
give very huge credit to my team because
i guess like opening wise and chess wise
um
i think uh
i can say it was like absolutely
dominance but i think
if we say about if we speak about the
opening battle
uh i guess it was uh
you know
quite in general was quite favorable for
us yeah i think that's definitely the
case um now you've talked a few times
about magnus's overall strategy
surprising you a little bit um what
about yours do you feel like you played
a little more restraint than you would
if you had to do this match all over
again
i know i i don't know but i mean okay in
general of course
i did a lot of just work it was also
part of the work was not only learning
new openings but also trying to adjust
my style
to a match so i mean of course the best
strategy
uh is
first of all is not to lose but once it
happens of course you have to adjust but
you know in general um i have to point
out that uh
it's hard to me you know i didn't really
analyze the previous match uh i mean
comparing with this one
but i would say that uh this time magnus
play was incredibly precise uh i mean in
general yes so maybe he was a little bit
uh
i don't know he played a little bit too
risky with white in general yeah so uh
he surely gave me some chances but as
black i mean he just
it was like quite impressive so despite
like getting some worse position in the
opening
uh you know basically more or less every
time uh he just uh
played
uh i think like four or five top
copyright choices in a row
and there you know this story basically
repeated
many times so in most at least okay in
most of our anti-martial games in the
game in the english opening so this was
like quite impressive so just i didn't
feel that i had some some real pressure
maybe we might maybe accept perhaps game
five but i don't think it was like
anything uh
too too brilliant but okay it was like
sort of a
sort of some perspective to to play on
uh but
yeah in general uh
i believe uh
a lot uh has changed after the game six
because uh
i mean obviously making all the draws
was not an option uh anymore uh but
on the contrary he just started to
playing strictly for a draw with both
colors and
uh i guess uh at least mentally this
helped him a lot
uh but i mean i mean of course uh
the energy level yeah becomes very
different uh
if you like win this game or if you lost
this game yeah i mean that much is going
to be talked about how pivotal that game
six was um getting back to an incident
that i don't think we've heard your take
on was the magnus carlson incident where
he twisted the knight and he threw his
hand back and i think most chess players
would agree especially because there was
no logical move with the knight that
there was no intent but still the rules
do say whether someone's at the board or
not you have to verbally say i adjusters
so now that we're far removed from the
match do you have any issue with what
happened uh during that incident
well uh
somehow i think there is some
story between me and hikaru back in 2015
on the world cup
and uh
yeah to a little bit you know to
uh
speak uh about about that case uh so it
was like about castling with two hands
or something but in general
i think he realized that this very role
of like touch move for
quite for quite some times yeah so it
was like not once or twice i think it
was like i mean okay that's like his
habit here so never say something
and uh my problem was actually that the
arbiter who was sitting there like and
recording moves and then okay when it
was like blitz or margadon okay uh it
was like
like three arbiters there and okay no
one ever even
ever interrupted
and uh no one ever said like i want okay
so
do something so i guess right after this
it was some some minor changes to the
feeder rules
about okay if arbiter says if he sees
evaluation he should have he should
interrupt yeah he should like uh
make uh
someone you know follow the rules and so
on
and um i would say it's a general uh
issue with uh
most of the churches tournaments so i
mean of course when they're speaking
about some tournaments with like 100
games played simultaneously you
basically don't have enough people and
it's um
uh probably everyone is responsible for
his on board yeah and uh he should i
don't know so stop the club call the
arbiter and so on but here i mean
basically
i don't really see
if it's
some such huge violation i don't think
so but in general yeah i mean if there
is an arbitrary he should
at least pay some attention what's going
on and uh
frankly i don't think that uh
two gentlemen who presenting their
arbiters
uh team
were
somewhat interested in what's going on
i mean except like checking uh official
checking for i don't know some
uh hardware you you bring with yourself
yeah so in general i would like uh to to
see some more dedication from the
arbiters uh during the game so for
example i mean okay you cannot um
i mean for example like in okay in
football yeah okay you have this war
yeah so uh you for example in uh
i don't know in
nfl you have this challenge yes so and
so on but uh every time you have a lot
of arbiters which are following the game
closely the the ifc violation they
interrupt anyway but in our i mean in
chess basically i mean okay there is not
such uh there is perhaps not such uh
no such tradition you have to to
sit near the board and look closely but
yeah that's what
i would probably expect or maybe okay if
you have like 10 cameras then maybe you
just don't pay attention you don't uh i
don't know uh check your email uh during
the during the match you don't uh i
don't know google or wikipedia or
whatever yeah or
find some memes on the internet or
whatever they they were basically doing
and
i guess
yeah that's uh that's what
hopefully will be changed in the future
uh but uh
yeah i mean the basically the attitude
of people because basically being just
arbitrary especially on a high
high level event is just you
should attend the
you know you should be presented with
playing call but uh
basically here your
uh
your responsibility ends yeah i think
that's that's how most of
uh people think yeah and that's
that's alice
the kind of
the way most of the arbiters act
so
i think this uh should be some somewhat
improved but uh i guess uh you know i
wouldn't be too happy if uh anyway
like accidentally or not accidentally
touch a piece i mean okay obviously the
right moves in that case almost loses or
something yeah so it's quite unfortunate
uh but i mean okay technically yes if
you didn't say something okay you
probably have to move with the knight uh
in that case but uh speaking of uh
people who are sitting there and not
paying attention to what's going on
in the match is
yeah
i think it is quite unfortunate okay and
very fascinating thoughts i'm just
curious if you were at the board and the
exact same incident occurred and you
witnessed all of it you would have said
something it sounds like
uh
well after you know after the match with
hikaru of course i would uh
i would do this but i mean at some point
uh
during i think during the bliss
tournament uh in um in moscow this uh
world rapid blitz i think he had some
blitz game against uh mikhail serine
and
uh yeah in the very opening the guy just
uh
touched the attached the power no
detached her advanced or adjusted but he
didn't see something and i mean clearly
making him uh make this move would
probably win the game for me immediately
but if it's all right so uh don't uh
don't need to stick to the kid but he
ended up beating me in the game so i was
a little bit uh you know a little bit
pissed
you know afterwards uh but uh in general
uh
yeah i think uh
the rules
are the same for everybody and uh you
know this
then you touch your move is somewhat so
you touch uh i mean someone to teach
kids uh when they you know
i come to the chess club for the first
time yeah so that's
quite a nice rule and
i would be happy and if everyone would
follow it okay fascinating uh well i
want to go out with a different kind of
question um you know obviously we want
to uh you know you're going to grow from
these games and from the experience and
we hope to have you back here but let's
not forget that you did win 800 000 euro
and that's not a small amount of money
so dubai has all kinds of fun things to
buy all kinds of luxury cars and watches
and everything um is there anything
you've had your eye on that you're going
to use uh the nearly 1 million dollars
to buy any kind of
you know present to yourself for what
you endured the last seven months well i
don't think i deserved any presence for
this match frankly speaking yeah but in
general okay maybe
yeah i still gotta find a place to live
in moscow so i think i'll i'll i'll try
to figure out maybe
uh
and that's something let's say in uh the
real team
okay well yeah it's uh nothing can buy
the world championship that's of course
the biggest prize but anyway we thank
you so much for your time john thank you
[Music]
you